[Musik]
guten Abend und willkommen zu einer
kompakten 19 uhr-ausgabe eine neue
peinliche Panne beschäftigt die
Bundeswehr für mehr als eine Milliarde
Euro wurden dringend benötigte digitale
Funkgeräte geordert aber der Einbau in
tausende Fahrzeuge vom Panzer bis
Geländewagen stockt es gibt gravierende
technische Probleme schlechte
Nachrichten für Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius die ihnen auf seiner Baltikum
Reise begleiten Andrea Maurer ist dabei
memory Airbase Estland der
Verteidigungsminister ist gekommen es
soll um das deutsche Engagement der
nato-ost-flanke gehen aber die
Beschaffungsprobleme der Bundeswehr sind
mitgereist seit dem Wochenende ist
bekannt dass Deutschland für 1,3
Milliarden Euro digitale Funkgeräte
gekauft hat ohne das geklärt ist wie sie
eingebaut werden können der Minister hat
davon offenbar erst aus den Medien
erfahren
im Dezember also vor meiner Zeit ich
wäre davon ausgegangen dass man diese
vor der Bestellung aber mindestens mit
der Bestellung oder über die Bankomat
die die Integration erfolgt der gesamte
Fuhrpark der Bundeswehr ist wohl
betroffen in manchen Fahrzeugen reicht
die Batterie nicht den anderen fehlt der
Platz 2025 will Deutschland der NATO
eine Division mit mehr als 16000
Soldaten stellen dafür muss es sich mit
den Partnern digital verständigen können
Verteidigungspolitiker aus Opposition
und Koalition sind alarmiert während
seiner Baltikum Reise telefoniert der
Minister viel auf den Pressekonferenzen
muss er auch zu den Funkgeräten immer
wieder Stellung nehmen die
Einsatzbereitschaft ist gewährleistet
aufgrund von Anfang an anderer
vorgesehener Funkgeräte so mein
Kenntnisstand heute und ich hoffe sehr
dass ich hier in den nächsten 48 Stunden
nicht wieder ändern muss hier im
Baltikum will der Verteidigungsminister
zeigen dass auf die Deutschen in der
Natur verlassen ist das
beschaffungschaos dass sich bei den
Funkgeräten abzeichnet wird ein Schatten
auch auf die Führungsrolle die
Deutschland gerne übernehmen will
morgen geht es für Boris Pistorius
zurück nach Berlin er hat Aufklärung in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
versprochen
eine Kehrtwende in der
Flüchtlingspolitik der
bundesinnenministerin hatte sich schon
abgezeichnet nennt sie Feser will
schleuserkriminalität und somit den
Zugang illegaler Flüchtlinge jetzt doch
mit stationären Kontrollen eindämmen am
Erfolg der Maßnahmen die an den Grenzen
zu Polen und Tschechien eingeführt
werden sollen wird auch gezweifelt Lars
Bohnensack
Razzia in den frühen Morgenstunden wie
hier im niedersächsischen Stade
durchsuchten 350 Polizisten in fünf
Bundesländern Wohnungen und Gebäude fünf
Personen wurden festgenommen mutmaßlich
Schleuser um die illegale Migration
einzudämmen hat Innenministerin Feser
angekündigt bislang von ihr abgelehnte
stationäre Kontrollen an der Grenze zu
Polen und Tschechien aufzubauen ich
erhoffe mir davon auch Erfolge es ist
wichtig dass wir das immer gemeinsam
aufsetzen mit der bereits existierenden
Schleierfahndung weil das die gesamte
Grenze abdeckt und das ist ja das
wichtige nicht nur in wenigen Stellen
sondern die gesamte Grenze die Union
Stellas Ankündigung in Frage schließlich
müsste die EU-Kommission noch zustimmen
es ist richtig hier Grenzkontrollen zu
Polen und Tschechien auch durchzuführen
die wir sie zu Österreich auch kennen
aber dies braucht eine Notifizierung in
Brüssel wenn es der Innenministerin
ernst ist dann muss diese Notifizierung
dringend Folgen Zweifel äußer allerdings
die Gewerkschaft der Polizei stationäre
Kontrollen an der Grenze könnten von
Schleusern wie von Flüchtlingen leicht
umgangen werden dazu kommt jeder der ein
Schutz ersuchen stellt in Deutschland
den muss ich nach Deutschland reinlassen
der muss bearbeitet werden vom Bundesamt
für Migration und Flüchtlinge von daher
ist es nicht richtig dass wir einfach
den Schlagbaum runter machen und sagen
du bleibst jetzt außen vor einig sind
sich die Regierungsparteien dass die
stationären Grenzkontrollen nur eine
Notfallmaßnahme sein sollen
in Bergkarabach sind bei der Explosion
eines Tanklagers mindestens 20 Menschen
ums Leben gekommen Medien berichten
sogar von deutlich mehr Opfern hunderte
wurden verletzt vor einer Woche hatte
aserbaidan die Region weitgehend erobert
seitdem fliehen die dort mehrheitlich
lebenden Armenier ins Nachbarland am Ort
der Explosion hatten flüchtende für
Benzin angestanden Sebastian eben dazu
es ist ein Inferno mitten im
Krisengebiet ein Treibstofflager in
Bergkarabach steht in Brand die Ursache
unklar doch die Krankenstationen sind
auch heute noch komplette überlastet es
gibt nicht genug Verbandsmaterial um
alle zu behandeln heute Mittag naht
Hilfe mehr als 20 armenische
Krankenwagen machen sich mit
aserbaidschanische Erlaubnis auf dem Weg
erst über die Grenze und dann über eine
extra geöffnete Gebirgsstraße nach
Bergkarabach sie sollen die Verletzten
nach Armenien bringen die Flucht der
Armenia aus Bergkarabach geht weiter
viele haben nach der Monate langen
Blockade und dem militärischen Angriff
Angst vor aserbaidschanischer Gewalt
wir haben nur unsere Dokumente den Wagen
etwas Geschirr und Decken mitgenommen
19000 Menschen sollen in den vergangenen
Tagen nach Armenien geflohen sein die
Regierung dort stellt sich auf
zehntausende mehr ein
[Musik]
knapp zwei Wochen nach dem Mord an einem
sechsjährigen in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
hat die Polizei einen Jugendlichen
festgenommen der 14-Jährige geht als
dringend tatverdächtig der jungen
erstochen zu haben hatte sich während
der Ermittlungen in Widersprüche
verstrickt entscheidend für die
Festnahme waren aber dNA Spuren an der
mutmaßlichen Tatwaffe
wer sein Elektroauto mit einem eigenen
mit eigenem Solarstrom laden möchte kann
dafür ab sofort eine neue staatliche
Förderung beantragen mit ausreichend
Geduld heute war das Kundenportal der
KfW Förderbank nämlich überlastet
subventioniert werden Kauf- und
Installation einer Ladestation mit einer
Solaranlage und einem Stromspeicher den
Zuschuss von maximal 10.200 Euro können
allerdings nur Hausbesitzer beantragen
zwar schön aber zu warm für die
Jahreszeit mehr gleich von ostentally um
21 Uhr 30 gibt es ein kurzes heute
journal mit Christian Sievers so viel
von uns morgen an dieser Stelle Barbara
halweg vielen Dank schönen Abend und
noch viel Spaß mit der zweiten Halbzeit
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja hoher Luftdruck
ist immer noch wetterbestimmt und
dementsprechend gibt es viel Nebel in
der kommenden Nacht vor allem nach Süden
in nach Norden in klartis teilweise auf
die Temperaturen sinken bis auf 5 Grad
in der Eifel ganz im Osten auf 14 und 16
Grad an der Nordsee morgen nach Nebel
Auflösung viel Sonnenschein im Süden
dann durchaus bis in die Mittagsstunde
noch relativ sehr Nebel und das bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 25 Teil 27
Grad hier verbreitet im Osten
Deutschlands ähnlich warm mit 27 Grad im
Südwesten und damit wünsche ich Ihnen
einen schönen Abend